it's great to have back on the program
today rick doblin who's the founder and
executive director
of maps the multi-disciplinary
association for psychedelic studies
which researches um legal developing
legal context for the careful
and beneficial uses of psychedelics and
marijuana
rick it's great to have you back on
today yes it's my pleasure i look
forward to our discussion
so i want to eventually get to what some
of the advancements and developments
have been since you and i last spoke a
couple of years ago
uh but first you you mentioned that you
were recently
in texas with a bunch of republicans
including
dan crenshaw who is not known typically
as the progressive beacon of hope to the
left
um but there seemed to be some sort of
camaraderie on the issue of using
psychedelics for
for uh veterans and in other contexts
yeah well uh representative crenshaw is
a former navy seal
right and he's heard now from quite a
number of navy seals who have
ptsd traumatic brain injury and the
treatments that they've been getting
from the va haven't been helping them
and so there's a group called vets by
amber and marcus capone
that brings particularly navy seals down
to mexico for ibogaine
which is a psychedelic drug from western
africa
and also 5meodmt which is a drug from
the sonoran toad
it's the most powerful of all the
psychedelics
and these navy seals have been finding a
lot of relief and other veterans as well
and so they've been sharing the news
with dan crenshaw
and also he's been hearing with some of
the veterans and others in our studies
with
mdma for ptsd and so now he has become a
major advocate
and he's working of all bipartisan way
with
tim ryan who's the congressman from ohio
friend of the show
very good guy yeah he's fantastic so
that they're the two of them though are
working together
we're getting ready to launch a bill to
give 25 million to the department of
defense
for psychedelic research for ptsd and
then another bill to give 25 million to
the va
and so what we're finding is that the
healing of veterans and others with
trauma from trauma is bipartisan and one
of the things that was so interesting at
the
discussion with dan crenshaw is here i
am surrounded by texas republicans
and i talked about how maps is a
non-profit we've raised over 115 million
dollars in donations to do this research
over our 35 years and i started by
saying that we've got this bipartisan
support
and i talked about rebecca mercer who
was the
family big supporters of trump and
bannon owned cambridge analytica which
we know about
scraping all the data from facebook so i
said we have support from rebecca mercer
from elizabeth koch whose father is
charles koch
and we have support from the rockefeller
family the
buffett family the pritzkers and i said
it goes all the way to george soros who
also supports us
and there was kind of this sort of
initial kind of joke or groan that
dan crenshaw made about george soros but
in the end it was like oh
it was like we're all in it together
that was the
the dominant message there there was one
thing that was really surprising to me
too
which was afterwards there was a a woman
who's um
a therapist used to be a therapist at
the houston va
and she does what's called emdr which is
an approach
towards helping people with ptsd and we
she talked about her husband was a
veteran and she's helped him with ptsd
she's very interested in our research
and then she said she's actually running
for congress i said that's really good
and then she said yeah and i'm running
against a republican
i said all right so we talked it was
like we
we exchanged cards it was very
interesting and then i get home to write
her a little email and i discover that
she's running
as a republican against a republican
who's not sufficiently right-wing she's
running to the right
of the currently existing republicans
but she likes what you're doing
she likes what we're doing because she
likes healing veterans so we've been
somehow or other able to take
psychedelics and
healing of trauma and move it out of
this
uh partisan struggle and it seems like
it's
it's going pretty well in that way yeah
that's it's an it's an incredible thing
and um i mean i would be curious to hear
since we last talked there were so many
things you were researching there were
so many things that you were studying
what are the sort of tangible
advancements
that have been made in this field of
using psychedelics and as well as
sometimes cannabis
uh for for a lot of different situations
well-being etc what advancements have we
made in the last couple of years
well in may we published we meaning maps
the we published the results from our
first phase three study of
mdma assisted psychotherapy for ptsd you
have to do two phase three studies to
get a drug approved by fda and they have
to approve safety and efficacy
and the first study was published in
nature medicine which is one of the most
highest impact scientific journals in
the world
and we had outstanding results better
than we even had hoped
and so what we showed is highly
significant results statistically
significant
large effect size excellent safety
record
the most amazing part is we work with
the hardest cases meaning
severe ptsd chronic ptsd
unlike many ptsd studies we enroll
people who've previously attempted
suicide
and what we showed is that two months
after the last experimental session
two-thirds
of these people no longer had ptsd it's
just
astounding the control group was 32
that's the group that got therapy
without mdma so 32 almost one-third no
longer had ptsd
from our therapy but when you add mdma
to
the therapy it's 67 percent no longer
have ptsd and of the one-third that
still
has ptsd most of them had what's called
clinically significant reductions of
ptsd symptoms
so we are the only group there that's in
phase three with psychedelics there's
now about a hundred plus psychedelic
companies for-profit companies
a few non-profits and they're either in
earlier stages of the research or
they're trying to develop new molecules
that they can patent new psychedelics
but we're the only ones in phase three
so that's the main development
there's also groups that have been
working with psilocybin
and they're doing well in phase two and
it's psilocybin for depression
psilocybin for
um nicotine addiction psilocybin for
alcoholism
um psilocybin for um
obsessive-compulsive disorder
we've also completed studies with
psilocybin excuse me with mdma for
social anxiety for life threat people
anxious about life-threatening illnesses
there was an incredible study done by
others that we helped with
um david nutt and ben cessa in england
mdma for alcohol use disorder
what it turns out is that trauma is what
drives a lot of drug addiction if you
help people deal with the traumas of
life
then they don't need to run away in
drugs and so we were able to show good
results in that
there's also starting to be interesting
promising findings with traumatic brain
injury that certain psychedelics can be
helpful with that
there's just a whole range of studies
that are now being
started with psychedelics that
are really showing enormous progress and
and one of the main
things that we know is that psychedelics
promote what's called neuroplasticity
and what that means is that our brains
are not fixed
they evolve as we grow we we know that
when we remember things there's
something
changed in our brain but more
importantly psychedelics can promote new
neural connections
in different kind of pathways so for
ptsd
we've there's been neuroscientists at
johns hopkins globe dolan who
did work with mdma giving them to
octopuses
and giving mdma to mice for the
octopuses
they're very solitary creatures and
they stay away from other octopuses
unless it's mating season which is the
end of their life
but you give them mdma and now they want
to hang out with other octopuses
and so these kind of pre-verbal deep in
our evolutionary history
mdma has this profound impact but in
mice when you give
mdma to mice it promotes oxytocin
release
which is the hormone of love they call
the cuddle hormone
the love nursing mothers the and
it promotes new neural connections new
growth of neurons in new pathways
what happens in these studies when with
the studies with people
is there like a placebo group where do
people know whether they're getting the
mdma or not because that seems like it
would be a relevant question in terms of
measuring the impact right
yeah that's a great question um my
dissertation at the kennedy school of
government
uh where i got my master's in phd was on
the regulation of the medical use of
psychedelics and one of the main things
i looked at was how do you do a
double-blind
study with a drug like a psychedelic
that's pretty obvious if you've taken it
it's not like you're taking different
pills and you don't notice
automatically what they do these are
very powerful drugs that change your
consciousness and you usually can tell
if that's happening sure
so a lot of my dissertation was about
how to solve this problem and
i thought i had the solution the
solution i thought was going to be
therapy with low dose mdma versus
therapy with full dose mdma
and the challenge was to find the dose
of mdma that was
high enough that enough people would
notice it and would
not be certain was it the low dose or
the high dose but that it wasn't
so high that you started getting all the
therapeutic potentials of mdma
and this is what we explored in phase
two
so maps i started in 1986 we started our
first phase one safety study in 1992
and in 1999 and 2000 we started the
phase two studies and that took us until
2016.
but what we discovered and this is i
guess you could say the
the the beauty and humility of
scientific research
is that you discover stuff that you
didn't realize was
actually going on or you discover that
you were wrong so what i discovered
through these studies and we tested uh
inactive placebo
with therapy 25 milligrams 30 milligrams
40 milligrams 50 milligrams 75
milligrams 100
125 and 150 and what we showed is that
the
therapeutic dose was lower than we
thought
75 milligrams was very effective
but that the lower doses they did cause
a certain amount of
uh inaccurate guesses but what they did
is they had an
anti-therapeutic effect meaning that
everybody still got better who got these
lower therapy plus lower doses
but when we looked at the data the
people that had therapy without
mdma did better than the people that had
therapy with low-dose mdma
and the best way to describe it it's
like if you're in an airplane and you're
about to take off sometimes there's
turbulence at the beginning
and then you get above the clouds and
then it's smooth sailing
so the low doses of mdma were like this
turbulence they
people were focused on their trauma they
were activated a little bit but the fear
reduction properties of mdma
weren't fully activated so right made
people uncomfortable
so when we went to the fda to design
phase three
i opened it up by saying that there's a
funny quote by a former president of
harvard
and what he said was never forget
there's always a harvard man
on the wrong side of every issue
and so i said in this case it's me
my dissertation which fortunately i
managed to get
my theory was wrong and that there is no
solution to the double-blind problem
and so we said to the fda we can give
you the blinding but you're going to
make it easier for us to find a
difference between the two groups and
the real question is
if you can do this work with therapy
without adding a drug
why add the drug so rather than adding a
drug that gives a little bit of blinding
it's more important that we test the
therapy by itself where it's the most
effective
and so the fda brought in what we like
to joke as the old wise man of the fda
his name is bob temple and he's been
there since 1972
and he was the office of science policy
and he came and he said
there is he agreed there is no solution
to the double-blind problem
and he said that there are other ways to
try to
reduce experiment or bias the
double-blind is really to make it so
that
you know you don't get biased results
that you don't find what you want to
find
right and so what they first off said is
what's called random assignment
that means everybody is similarly
motivated and then they get randomized
either to the
control group or the experimental group
the other thing they said is that the
independent raiders who evaluate
the outcomes that you can't have the
therapist say oh did this person get
better or not or even the person
themselves
to uh to do it that you need independent
raiders
and this is done through an hour-long
interview with the patient about all of
their symptoms
and so we have these independent raiders
in a very robust system we have over 20
of them trained by the boston veterans
administration
where they develop the measure they do
it by random assignment
meaning it's all telemedicine so they
don't know
the patient where they are in the
treatment process
they don't know if they've got mdma or
the placebo so
based on that the fda said that they
would agree with us that we would do
therapy without mdma versus therapy with
mdma
even still there's about 10 of the
people that are confused
about what they got which is pretty
astonishing but sometimes people
resist the emotional effects of mdma
because they're so scared of what's
going on they have kind of a muted
effect
so there's a little bit of confusion but
we also negotiated with the european
medicines agency we're trying to
negotiate all over the world
to globalize mdma therapy and so the
european medicines agency
went through the same analysis and they
also agreed with the fda
that it's therapy without mdma versus
therapy
with mdma and therapy with inactive
placebo
and we're also doing research in israel
and canada
we've done some in brazil we're just
moving forward into australia
so i think the the frustrating part in a
way is that there is no good solution to
the double-blind problem but
the fda realizes that that even though
the methodology doesn't work
people are still suffering you still
have to do the research and you still
have to design the studies as best you
can
right so the breakthrough that we had
was uh
our first phase three study being
tremendously successful and so we are
now doing the second phase three study
we do have a site here in boston and uh
many of your listeners may have heard of
a book called the body keeps the score
it's by a fellow bessel vanderkok who's
a psychiatrist here in boston
amazingly by the way he published the
book six years ago
about trauma and two weeks ago it was
the number one bestselling book on the
new york times bestseller list of
print and ebook combinations so there's
an enormous cultural interest now in
trauma
and bessel is the principal investigator
of our boston site
and he thinks that mdma is the most
effective thing he's seen for ptsd in
his entire career
yep so it's uh very much excited it's
incredible the advancements that are
being made and
uh yeah the body keeps the score great
really a great book for anybody to read
regardless of one situation a uh an
important book uh rick
always so glad to hear about the things
that are going on
one last thing please okay just just
that we think that the second phase
three study
we will have um completed in october of
2022
okay and we think by the end of 2023 we
expect to have
fda approval and then we're training
we want to train 25 000 therapists
and set up thousands of psychedelic
clinics throughout the united states and
thousands more throughout the world
ambitious
and uh fantastic rick doblin from from
maps
always so great speaking to you rick
great thank you for having me davis